bonjour mais petit bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui je dois remplacer au pied
levé votre professeur de physique je
vous ferez halle aux grains cours de
mécanique générale sur le ressort à bout
du fil on comprime un ressort n'est ce
pas plus
il se détend comme celle ci mais eux
mais ce qui aura ça dans le racer abouda
comme l'ont dit eux clide et n'est ce
pas c'est son dynamisme qui s'alimente
au bout d'un flux à saint lô l'on n'est
ce pas plus
cette course est longue
voyez-vous bien voici messieurs ce qu en
peu de mots nous pouvons dire sur le
ressort à bouloc
c'est bien mais je n'en démordrais quand
même pas la douceur de la biche et des
griffes du félin ça y est au sam amidon
stationnement non à ma personne et mon
beau non verbale et ses mots one time
password mot bombe aux sapins
ras des forêts
nous avons ce soir là un anniversaire en
famille et nous attendons notre invité
d'honneur monsieur le duc de jardin le
comte et la comtesse du ballot de
challignac et leurs chiens
le général de verdel bon pied bon oeil
mon bonheur mon général parfait son lot
de corps le colonel la cac
le baron de lula maman ta vie à de
langlas de sarria de galles pas leur
aide ou sa fille gens rejettent le mois
notre invité d'honneur au pays se passe
c'est exercer un sabotage mais non mais
coûte que ça se fait dans toutes les
familles quand il ya un anniversaire ça
se fait dans les familles mais mais la
télévision ça fait pas tout la non
envoyez-moi cent mille volts
allez monsieur gilbert bécaud
vive la foule mois président otis amène
d'ailleurs je voudrais vous dire
présentement que cette conférence de
presse doit se passer dans la bonne
humeur
oui et je tiens à vous signaler par la
même occasion que si les journalistes
ont des présentement des questions à me
poser je suis toute ouïe répondre lui
même question pour l'afrique en matière
d'image mais si le président maréchal
mon frère je voudrais savoir pourquoi
très bonne question je répondrai tout
cas le bon truc question pour le journal
minute
voilà ce que je voulais vous demander
c'est que par rapport à ce qu'ils
croyaient pas que en ce qui concerne les
études comme moi je ne comprends pas non
moi c'était moi pour le journal pin ut
voilà ce qui se passe c'est que j'ai
l'impression que malheureusement il ya
des petits problèmes en ce qui concerne
le wet water guette je vends pas vous
oui pour ici dimanche le couple dada se
sépare la princesse anne
ce couple est vaine mais on dit tout de
même qu'il y à anguilles sous roche
entre la princesse
allez vous remplacer sun est une
excellente cavalière
ce n'est pas une raison pour affirmer
que anne est adam
pour total et on dit monsieur le
président que les noirs vous voyez ce
que je veux dire oui madame tout temps
le oui pour l'équipe quel sens peur est
ce que vous croyez pas que il serait bon
que disons que ce serait assez valable
pour vous si vous aviez sur les stades
de haute compétition parce qu il faut
dire que chez vous vous êtes assez nul à
ce qu'est ne vous inquiétez pas nous
avons toujours battu les blancs en neige
et bien il n'y a plus de question donc
je terminerais c'était conférence de
presse un tir à cette maxime de mon
petit livret blanc qui dit avoir connu
un moment kung fu panda katrina
autrement dit plus gênant le moins vite
moins j'avance plus fort de toute
manière dada reste à celle de ce mal
quand même
c'est ta dernière chanson ça c'est ma
dernière chance mais non tu perds mais
je me permets de te dire tu as oublié
oui enfin j'ai pensé que c'était pas la
peine qu'on sentait que ça se passe au
tfc c'est sûr mais moi je le prends pas
ce que je vais te dire j'ai l'impression
que oui c'est pas moi qui prendrai j'ai
des problèmes tout ça et pourtant je
sais ce qu'il faut faire je sais comment
sont les femmes c'est c'est la douceur
de la biche l'est les griffes du félin
enfin tous armés mais c'est ça les
femmes non mais oui peut-être mais non
ils font les il faut les prendre
beaucoup plus réaliste tu vois et puis
un peu actor studio c'est à dire je t
attends bouge pas tu restes là à l'eau
et cancer attend sa réponse
ça y est alors chérie je t'épouserais
jamais parce que je t'aime trop j'espère
rester
oui chérie oh là là faudrait tellement
que tu viennes habiter chez moi ou juste
à côté parce que j'aime bien mais 16
alors chérie chéri je voudrais qu'on
parte tous les deux tout seul tous les
deux tout seul avec mon père ma mère
l'est du pont la caravane tout on irait
au bord de la méditerranée
il aurait la belle-mère bleus devant
nous ma belle-mère en noir derrière
tu m'entends ferry et que je caresserait
doucement tout doucement notre berger
allemand oui chérie avec moi tu auras
tout ce que tu voudras tout tu pourra
garder les bijoux de ta mère la voiture
de ton père tout tu me feras ton salaire
à la fin du mois cherry et puis le soir
tous les deux devant la cheminée on se
regardera et puis tu me nettoiera les
verres de contact et plus tard encore
beaucoup plus tard chéri quand le temps
aura marqué ton si doux visage et bien à
ce moment-là chérie si je suis encore
libre je t'épouserais c'est là que
maintenant nous allons véronique sanson
qui va se met alors à près ghsr avec
elle pour voir si ça marchait
nous
je crois que
après tout ce que tu viens de me dire je
dois partir surtout après tout ce que tu
viens de me dire je dois partie surtout
après tout ce que tu viens de me dire je
dois partir surtout après tout ce que tu
viens de dire
ce doit partir c'est la fin d'une belle
histoire
ça va pas que ça c'est pas bon il faut
jouer plus à l'américaine il faut jouer
décontracté il faut jouer avec les
objets vous avez les objets vous jouez
avec les objets décontracté à l'actor
studio comme effet james dean il faut
faire american act le studio décontracté
vous comprenez oui la gauche vous
n'aurez pas je sais me débrouiller comme
vous dites que c'est pas un problème à
l'américaine à tour tout comme on fait
pas un problème je crois que
après tout ce que tu viens de me dire je
dois partir c'est la fin d'une belle
histoire fantastique extraordinaire ça
c'est sensible et ça ça me plaît ça et
voyez-vous les autres comédiens français
et étrangers qui étaient ici prêt à être
auditionné vous avez chacun est dit dans
le texte de votre choix
c'est à dire un poème une fable un
extrait de tirages classiques ou encore
vous dites un poème ou encore jean fabre
si vous voulez vous dites les critères
classiques ou encore un point positif a
pas on va demander à monsieur moi
monsieur je suis belle
monsieur oui mais par l'accent beaucoup
travaillé laissez-moi jugé sous moi donc
cette troupe s'avance et porte sur le
front le maire d'assurer nous partîmes
500 mais par un prompt renfort nous nous
vîmes trop aimé l'on arrive en tout cas
tout à nous voir marcher avec un tel
visage les plus éprouvantes et
reprenaient leur courage vous passez à
côté
vous allez signer le contrat maintenant
je vais demander à monsieur phonak baird
paul caille friedrich à lens car
hellmuth bunds allemands comment l'avez
vous devinez
comme ça pouvait lire un texte lu et
bien sûr mais avant je voudrais vous
dire et comme j'aime beaucoup vos
artistes français dans la mousse curie
petula clark terry 4 ait alida etc des
rares et scélérate cnra les textes là
franck rosenthal ganaderos l'entraîneur
français mais rien pour arranger tout le
monde l'a vu et bien sûr il faisait beau
aujourd'hui sur la compagnie nous avions
des idées mon père le meilleur
mon grand père m'a cramé est ce qu'il
restait de mon arrière quand on est
heureux de prendre la 4 e chevaux et
d'aller gambader nous nous installâmes
au bord de l'eau n'osera 2 à 1 m 25 1 m
30 paf libre et s'est achevée et à la
fin du déjeuner mais grandir je vais
vous raconter une histoire eux c'est
l'histoire de tout vous ne me trouverez
dans toutes les histoires de toutous 20
et tous deux ont aidé à les connais et
ils chutent alors la maîtrise les
remakes
elle vit dit tout le monde comme un air
de là vers la rive la maîtrise d'oeuvre
au pouvoir des sacs poubelles dori gold
by gold 2 1 pour la tour de répondre
madame jay les îles d'aland grillé la
course est très bien celui-là vous
passez à côté vous signer le contrat
il y en a plus c'est fini très bien allô
oui mais l'aspect mon capitaine je viens
d'un coin ces trois là oui il vient de
signer un contrat de cinq ans pour la
légion étrangère
mais la sptr au capitaine mais respecte
dacquois
américain actuel l'imitateur tués j'ai
beaucoup mieux que sa tueuse en amont
oui mon cher momo faire parlons sasha
enfin si tu veux je trouve que des
imitateurs il y en a beaucoup
c'est bien je ne les critique pas c'est
formidable mais si tu veux il moi ce que
j'aime ce sont les choses réalistes
tu vois si je voulais me taise on ferait
vraiment des kilos en trop mais ce qui
est difficile c'est le faire
réaliste tu vois par exemple si je veux
unités un petit oiseau de la forêt noire
héros minable tu vois et c'est pas fini
ça c'est dur mais alors je peux faire
aussi la sirène d'un paquebot qu'il est
dans la brume comme la merguez il est
dans la semoule
tu vois
tu vois bien voilà les claquettes comme
john kerry ah oui moi j'ai essayé je
suivais mes adversaires et non mais
c'est pas simple mais par exemple le
marteau piqueur aussi
oui ça réveille mais il faut le faire
mais le plus difficile mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs mon frère sacha
c'est de faire les quatre ensembles
également santé nationaux c'est pas
possible non non
salut moi je suis venu pour la guitare
tu vois pas ce que sacha il en pas de
vachement de la guitare qui voient ça me
fait vachement flippais parce que tu
vois c'est plus gratifiant que le piano
tu vois puis d'abord c'est plus pratique
à trimballer dans les rues et tu vois
pas ce que piano dans les rues tu as et
pas tellement pratique tu as donc
surtout au quartier latin tu vois tu
chantes avec une guitare c'est super
écologique et où tu vois mais tu vas pas
laisse tomber
non tu vas surtout sacha il chante en
anglais style us tu vois c'est super tu
vois c'est sacha hisser ses chasses sa
chasse sachet sachez enfin iiii connais
tu vois moi c'est pas vraiment extra tu
vois pas ce que j'ai des gros doigts tu
vois alors je chope trois corps d'un
coup c'est vachement mer dont tu vois
trois cordes d'un coup le problème tu
vois je suis allé à nashville parce
qu'ils en font des spéciales et tout
avec des câbles de grues tu vois c'est
vachement pratique les câbles d'uruguay
et puis alors le manche est comme un
pain de six livres c'est super extra
enfin en attendant tu vois je travaille
les claquettes tu vois comme ça
falah ça ta peau parce que j'ai des
baskets mais parce que je les ai
confectionné moi même façon artisanat tu
vois
mais ce qu'ils voient eux moi je j'ai
arrêté l'alcool la donne moi un petit
nombre à café café calva double al kalba
décembre et qui a fait ça fait léger
temps raconté mines oui ça vous vous
lassez galley la forme et j'en ai une
hotte avoir broyé pour m ah bon à
siauliai me fait marrer way he dollar
highway expliquez vous alors à temps
alors cette fois on achète pas d'oran
comment cette fois l'offre est ouvert
aux étudiants
gareth bale est le salut est bientôt
fini voyez tout à fait régulièrement
elle dit libé s'il vous plaît c'est la
chaîne c'est la fin moi j'aime bien
aussi thierry derrière leur chanteur a
raconté jean marc je suis très ému
bonjour pour votre côté pour leucate et
assoyez-vous là les mecs en ce temps là
jésus jésus à un quota six territoires
non ça va en ce temps là jésus dit à ses
disciples
les petits mecs si qu'on allait faire
une virée sur le lac de tibériade
qu'edith bongo qui fait saint-pierre
vendeuse qui est des jeunes vu des
bikers toi tu vas tu as a souhaité dès
qu'ils aient fait jésus parce que je
veux dire entretient aussi c'est que ils
enfourchent leur moto a ici en direction
le lac tibériade
or là j'ai les yeux qui était pas chef
de bande pour rien du tout il fait lé
mexique on allait faire du ski nautique
qui fait du ski nautique
ouais ok ils disent tous sauf saint jean
baptiste saint jean baptiste qui avaient
des rhumatismes
oui dans les genoux à force de rester
dans la flotte ont vite fait idée car
direction la baraque du ski nautique
tranquille manque de pot fermé cause de
sa batte a dit donc c'est un programme
qui fait saint pierre parce qu' on va
quand même pas rentrer pour voir à la
télé gilad dans sabbath est à vous qui
veut
on laisse tomber je fais quoi boire les
potes qui fait santana qui avait touché
j'avais touché le jazz c'est dans
l'ordre que la leaf jésus vise un peu
l'artiste
et puis là jésus y pensons et l'en
excuser way i coups reçus lors il fonce
vers la flotte était pas l eia qui fait
polémique sans les skis sans les skis et
c'est ainsi mes bien chers frères kg jeu
et marcha sur les os
le match a accueilli des matches les
armes
will i am in hybrid engine du show c'est
beaucoup mesdames et messieurs heimbach
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs je suis
très heureux de vous voir aussi nombreux
ce soir
ouellette et bien mesdames et messieurs
ce soir à g a well as ge oil sands un
vrai problème de serieux quelque chose
de très important à venir
et oui qu'est-ce que vous avez aimé mon
interprète tandis que hyères tonight we
ce soir
ringo sur la nda sacha au petit gars 1 1
voilà comment
moi je m'en vais vous vous vous commencé
mon tour par une histoire qui j'espère
va vous faire rire serait l'histoire de
5,5 me marre des gens dans la mare
montrons sales histoires d'à français
qui racontera nom anglais et qui lui
fait du yo-yo poil et buffet en lui même
face à enfin s'est pas rendue you do you
de poil ça veut dire comment vas-tu
autres poils mais moi j'ai j'ai arrangé
en anglais parce que c'est plus moderne
je trouve que ça inclut drôle de faire
ça et puis l'on triés pour être et toi
le d'attentes avant c'est à dire que
avant au 10è et toile à matelas mais
avec la démocratisation de camping
campus à équivoque
enfin l'importance c'est que de pouvoir
faire parce que voyez vous ce qu'il ya
d'important dans la commune car l'heure
actuelle ah bah ça doit savoir évoluer
ces veaux et silence dans la classe
j'avais entendu ce que j'ai dit ça
suffit
euh j'ai repéré vous un bon ça suffit
aujourd'hui nous allons faire une dictée
et nous sommes le 26 août
c'est ça le 26 août bien le garder le
calme
c'est le titre le gas in et des thons
rouges des virgules
lorsque son entrevue avec en va des
points virgules
mais est venu pour lui le vide est
devenu il a enfin à la pêche à la ligne
pour un rêve est encore acheté points et
étant costaud mais ouvrez la parenthèse
quoique tout pout but c'est son problème
fermez la parenthèse et en l'effective
en définitive
hélas à crédit il alla en raid point
final
relisez bon
moi je peux aller au 0 au chalet le
rejoindre aux gens aussi vos je suppose
qu'il ya plus plat ce salon très beau le
but le but les étrangers bravo 18 tu
seras un homme mon fils
et moselle et moselle une demoiselle
vous voilà arrivés à la fin de votre
dernière année d'études dans notre chère
institutions d'éducation sexuelle
vous êtes actuellement de grandes jeunes
filles oui vous êtes de grande jeune
fille maintenant et vous devez savoir
que les enfants arrivent à cheval si
j'ose dire sur les cigognes et qu'elles
viennent remplir nos cheminées de petits
enfants tout rose enroulés dans leur
l'ange au milieu du bec de la fameuse
cigognes précédemment cités maintenant
comment procède t exactement le papa et
la maman
eh bien le soir lorsqu'ils sont dans la
chambre à coucher
le papa baisse la lumière et sort son
catalogue
alors là à savon voilà le papa et la
maman commande un petit frère ou une
petite soeur par la poste
et puisque vous ne devez pas ignorer
ceux ci en ce dernier jour comment
reconnaît reconnaît-on les petits
garçons des petites filles voilées
je sais je sais je sais eh bien on vote
oui j'oubliais c'est très simple
soulever les draps et l heure à ce
moment là
on peut simplement distinguer que les
petites filles ont des layette rose et
les petits garçons des layettes bleus
le segal il a formé les tétées fois un
petit graal que la verena bofi et les
tests voilà comme ça serait arlette
comme ça là le droit si tôt qu'est ce
que l'art et vsd à aller voir des 3t
maison à côté si la formule est toujours
là et la rave et frappe la porte si elle
vous plaît s'il vous plaît arrêtez rien
d'être ciel au pied et une heure
pareille meinert pas rien d'être ouvre
la porte et lula pour que ce que tu veux
et quand je veux dire une chose c'est
difficile pour moi parce que j'ai rien à
ma fille a rien dit aux deux camps
propre site
qu'est ce que tu dis aux tons chauds que
c'est la chaleur à crever qu'est ce
qu'ils faisaient
j'y faisais rien d'être comme ça j'ai
testé fait tout le pognon qui avait
gagné qui a volé acheter la dauphine
après tu as acheté la floride tiens
steel a dit l'ingénieur d'autres
voitures pour ça et maintenant tu viens
me réclamait de l'argent est tout à leur
travail
la côte moi s'il vous plaît je suis très
malheureuse
c'est à voter mais des artistes et des
riens détente il va manger lorsque
devant moi j'ai les costco spolier les
cosmo temps circonscrit ça va alors tu
t'en vas seul mot paix c'était vrai
schéma leur île et claque la porte au
nez cas ce qu'affirme la renamo fait
c'est fini
c'est alors qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
que la cigale et grève la forme et elle
a beaucoup de l'argent au sein des
pognon hossa et bouffe trop et beauf
taureaux et boeufs trop il est né
fractus du myocarde
alors est claire moralité des bof bof
pas de grève quand même si elles vont
templier merci moi je suis pas don sert
à rien de bon je suis juste une auteure
dramatique que j'ai fait un mètre 72 73
26 c'est le groupe lee mears
je viens juste donné un petit coup de
barre 9e qui juste avant que les autres
numéros à smara nombreuses vagues
d'assaut cl vous plaît merci
moi j'ai souvent la notion allocation
tranquille tout ça cl vous plaît merci
les tests blu laisse tomber le torchon
c'est un mot clé moi je travaille sont
23 heures par semaine et que zidane sont
43 francs par mois soit quand on s'est
levé merci j'ai cela que je mange les
causses qu'oscar négo de temps en temps
les costco seront pour permettrent j'y
ai réfléchi car ça fait mal au foie et
aux reins mondiaux s'il vous plaît merci
crc spg
2h06 avec les voitures
je l'adoré je vendais le peso si le
dauphin avec les décrire magnéto bardot
j e donna albert john capitaine haddock
temps de mélo marge de l'armée à savoir
la navale l'aspect plaidé des ponts
professeur tournesol savons si elle vaut
plus merci j'ai l'accord de taëf
roquettes de trois heures j'ai les
antibrouillards les klaxons
tentant pour une choquante et si elle
vaut plus parce que quand on réfléchit
thomazo c'est aux dépenses toute la
semaine fédérale j'ai raison ces replis
bien avec les copains h la caravane va
mais font aller voir la petite soeur de
grands parents souhaitent